this could be the worst medical show in
these to read medical shows I heard
there's a new medical drama floating
around on YouTube called adAway general
I'm ready for a cringe-worthy YouTube
medical show as first-year TVs you guys
will be on pediatrics
you'll help with clerical work Transpo
keeping patient's company yes
babysitting great that's right Georgia
this feels like the exact same intro
that I think Grey's Anatomy started when
we did our first Grey's Anatomy review
it feels like a little hazing is
happening here and we don't haze our
volunteers in the hospital emmalin's
baby's hands patient dr. Henry and
everyone across Metro somewhat similar
does happen in a hospital we have a
triage nurse for example if I have a
patient in my outpatient center that I
need to be seen in the ER I call ahead
the nurse triage is it gets a doctor
ready if we need a trauma Bay they get
that ready all the equipment you want to
be prepared this is my she's our top
second-year she's gonna finish the tour
while I go home I'll be back when I can
I also didn't know that volunteers have
years of seniority like residents have
that like first year second year third
year fourth year and they have seniority
over each other I feel like this show is
grooming teens to become hardcore face
of grace having me
what were those chest compressions what
is this you gotta use the full weight of
your body oh this is gonna suck
it's gonna be amazing I'm not gonna lie
the person who's there on the first day
of introductions and they're taking
notes
I was always super intimidated by that
person should I be taking notes am I
missing something
what if they're gonna know something I
don't and then I realize sometimes you
need to take notes and sometimes you
just need to be there present as a human
cuz alums train here for everyone make
sure everyone eats at least half before
you leave what happened to a proper
orientation teaching them how to use
safety equipment knowing when to notify
senior staff putting on gloves and gowns
these things need to be taught and I
hope they were checked for their
immunizations because the last thing we
want is our volunteers spreading illness
throughout the hospital why did you
volunteer to work at a hospital I got
arrested beeps juvie
[Music]
do not blow into a glove with your mouth
before you put it in a it's not really
hygienic because you have a lot of
bacteria in your mouth
but number two there's humidity that
comes from your mouth and have you ever
tried to put your hand into a wet moist
glove ah and it's hard fun fact those
beds are accurate they're legit and
they're insanely expensive ICU beds are
twenty five to thirty thousand dollars
each
I've seen those go even higher and
medical beds which are just the plain
ones are five to ten thousand event
imagine a 300 bed hospital it's a lot of
moolah I'm a little worried right now
cuz I'm losing a lot of blood and my
favorite sweatshirt you should be fine
to wait a little if you didn't artery
you would have passed out by now oh we
have pre-med students up in here she's
like if you hit an artery you wouldn't
be here right now yes but why in the
world is she making contact with a
patient and giving medical advice huge
nono to our volunteers can you be there
can you help them out can you do all
these things yes you're not trained to
give medical care no matter how many of
my youtube videos you watch six-year-old
female degree burns possible smoke
inhalation we couldn't get a line in
give me a 24 needle norepinephrine what
else can I do oh you've done more than
enough you can go back to your normal
duties okay she's close to coding come
on show me a vein Acuras she's close to
coding what if a patient's not breathing
that means they're coding that means
they're dead and you need to bring them
back to life and that means you need to
do chest compressions chest compressions
chest compressions and as doctor asking
for a 24 gauge needle I don't even
understand what he's hoping to do here
he's starting to try to start an IV you
don't start an IV with the 24 gauge
needle you start with an 18 gauge needle
which is much wider none of this makes
sense
[Music]
I love that the doctor while he's
reaching for the syringe he's reaching
for it he's still tapping on her elbow
like what are you doing my man
what do you tap him for what are you
trying to find what did you do to get
arrested in prison you're never supposed
to ask about the crime come on dude
you're the last one you have to eat hey
don't ignore me um hey Jack maybe try a
gentler approach so akward cringy hey
why don't you try a gentler approach
Stevie sweetie you need to eat to get
big and strong and feel better
nah it's actually really good let me
show you
she really take a bite off the spoon and
then she is giving the same spoon to the
child oh I love that my man is just
standing there in a shearling jacket
maybe take it off make yourself like
you're at work put on a uniform not a
fancy jacket like you're part of an
after-school play for the Lost Boys what
are you doing home don't come any closer
I don't think that's gonna hurt anyone
depends where I put it
the cardiac rhythm behind them is like
this scariest rhythm ever and there's
ten of them go figure why in different
colors they were like let's just put
them all on the screen because they're
colorful squeeze as tight as you can
I don't worry about hurting her longer
and we're in what is he doing this is
just insanity keep up the rescue meds
nothing changed on the screen what is
happening this could be the worst
medical show in the history of medical
shows doc McStuffins was more accurate
bustling are you back here just waiting
to get my stitches removed mind if I
take a look two problems here one why in
the world do you go to the emergency
room to get your stitches removed you
could go to your primary care doctors
office and save a huge er bill and a
wait in the ER - why is the volunteer
taking a look at anything medical that
is not ethical it's wrong
scissors look like they healed nicely
shouldn't have too much of a scar this
is like what people must think happens
in hospitals like the writer was I
wonder what volunteers do they must help
with patients no they don't
can you imagine someone with zero
medical experience giving out medical
advice oh wait that's like Gwyneth
Paltrow in goop I guess it does happen
nurse sandy told me be careful one of
the boys believe the other and is pretty
dangerous these are scary I've never
seen a medical uniform specify the age
of the person wearing it it doesn't say
medical volunteer it says teen volunteer
who needs to know that information
where you headed I was on my way to the
supply room or supplies that's funny
so was I
I didn't know you're a doctor Henry's
protege I didn't know that volunteers
were considered protegees I used to
think that would be a role for residents
or med students nurses smarter than
their sexy I read that some way I
appreciate it though
I like people representing smart folks
the fact that he said he read it
somewhere means he reads I'm so sorry
you're hurting how about a nice factor
that I know I'm good can I get you some
pudding juice you know it's really
important whenever a patient is admitted
into a hospital or coming into the
emergency room there are certain orders
that we place as doctors whether or not
a patient is allowed to eat and what
kind of diet they have to follow because
some patients have trouble swallowing
certain foods some patients should be
NPO which means nothing by mouth because
they're going for a procedure or perhaps
a surgery so the fact that these kids
are running around the hospital and
offering people food while is nice in
theory that's not their job and they
need to be really careful who they're
feeding because if someone is going for
a surgery in an hour and they give them
a sandwich
that's a problem because the surgery is
gonna get canceled you know I've never
been in a fight maybe you can give me
some pointers I'm not sure this device
that he has on his head I've never seen
it before I honestly don't think it's a
medical device but because I haven't
seen it because I'm not technically a
trauma surgeon I'm not gonna comment on
it look shady them really don't know
where the bandages are oh I do I just
needed an excuse to get you in here
[Music]
what is it with you kids you can't
follow the simplest instruction I love
all the medical dramas are all doctors
doing everything transporting patients
ordering tests performing the surgeries
talking to the patients everything is
them and in this show
the volunteers are the only ones they're
treating the patients they're breaking
up the fights they're making out in the
hallways what is going on include other
characters health care is a
collaboration
you're supposed to protect your patient
kid what are they police officers you're
supposed to protect and serve as a
volunteer can you tell me what happened
to Holden no updates give
[Music]
Holden has a severe heart condition we
don't give patient information out to
volunteers just cuz they have crushes on
them patient information is a protected
entity oh my god for a chocolate bar is
he gonna be okay it's not a good
prognosis but he's at a way to enroll
getting the best care there is I may
have to disagree with you on that little
point in fact probably more like a Dawei
funeral home as opposed to a doorway
General Hospital just say here's a
higher quality medical show doc
McStuffins yes it's a cartoon about a
preschooler on someone a little older
check out my man Doogie Howser here Neil
Patrick Harris and pH which one you
click as always stay happy healthy
[Music]